welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the latest Star Wars mystery is
uh who's this guy the name's maroke a
former Jedi Hunter now a mercenary in
the search for Grand Admiral thrawn his
face covered in a mask and Because the
Internet loves to White Ranger this
stuff morocc is now speculated to be
everyone from Ezra Bridger or Sam
Whitmore as Galen Merrick Starkiller or
ahsoka's past Jedi Temple Frenemy Baris
offy that one was one I speculated but
to be honest folks I think most of these
theories are silly there's a lot of
confusion going around about Ezra and
Rebels and how credits work exactly so
in this video since Baroque now speaks
in episode 3 let's clear things up look
further under that helmet really the
best place to learn about the history of
inquisitors and to really get to know
who Ezra Bridger really is is to watch
our four-part Rebels recap series all
four videos now on the channel to get
you up on all the episodes the
characters the timeline the Easter eggs
and the lore that you need to know okay
the official Star Wars website describes
morocc thusly once in Inquisitor hunting
Jedi for the Empire The Mysterious
maroque now works as a mercenary hired
by Morgan ellsmith to carry out dark
Deeds fully encased in bettered battle
armor the warrior still carries a red
double-bladed saber with a circular Hilt
battered huh sounds like something on
Guy Fieri's menu at flavor town we deep
fried better this bad boy and some
donkey sauce
anyway this confirms that Baroque was an
Inquisitor during the days of the Empire
and that now after the Empire has fallen
morocc now works as the mercenary and
while this description's wording avoids
a gender balance goal in episode 2
implied he was male marook will complete
his task so to me this is enough to
eliminate Baris offy as a suspect the
stunt actor who plays him is also male
now those wondering if morocc might be
Ezra Bridger could be thinking about
Ezra's Dark Side leanings during the
rebels series but folks that face was
limited to Seasons two and three the
period in which Maul worked to corrupt
Ezra using the Sith holocron up until
the point of Maul's death at the end of
season 3 in the Twin Suns episode we did
not get any Dark Side moments with Ezra
in season 4 as the mysticism surrounding
his character shifted to the loath
Wolves and the world Between Worlds he
easily resisted Palpatine's Temptation
in the finale episode there was no dark
side in him at that point our man Ezra
had never served as an Inquisitor during
the days of the Empire he hated
inquisitors and the whole point of this
series
Ezra is in a far away Galaxy morocc is
not Ezra now maroke does finally speak
in this episode saying three lines from
under that helmet
on the way nothing now in past episodes
when Morocco gave only a physical
performance the character received no
acting Credit in the closing credits but
for episodes one and two Morocco's stunt
work was credited to stunt performer
Paul Darnell and now in episode 3 among
the main building of the actors in the
episode the speaking roles the character
is now credited entirely to Paul Darnell
this change happened on the episode The
Character began talking now last week
people began noticing among the
additional voices section at the very
end of the credits in a sound Department
listings for episodes one and two and
now 3 Sam whitworth's name is listed
there Sam Whitmore of course the Beloved
figure in Star Wars fandom as the voice
of maul and Clone Wars and Rebels but
before that he provided the voice and
liked this for Galen Merrick AKA
Starkiller in the 2008 game Star Wars
the Force Unleashed in its 2010 sequel
Galen Merrick is Darth Vader's secret
Apprentice categorized technically as a
Legends character but you know what who
knows with the way Dave filoni loves to
reconfirm Legends categorize details as
Canon so could maroc be Galen Marek with
his similar sounding last name ah here's
the thing folks Sam Whit were often and
does credited and uncredited Voice work
for all of these titles he's kind of
like always hanging out in the room they
love him his name has appeared in
additional voices for all three episodes
of Ahsoka so far right beside names like
Matthew Wood a sound editor who also
lent his voice to animated versions of
characters like General Grievous and bit
Fortuna and Helen Sadler who voiced Jen
erso in the Battlefront game Rey and the
animated Star Wars Lego titles Dr
skalder in the bad badge and in Ahsoka
she voiced the HK assassin Droid leader
in episode one not only that if you look
at the additional voices section of
every episode of the Mandalorian season
3 earlier this year Sam whitworth's name
appears in every single episode of that
too and no Galen Mara Cameo showed up in
those Eight Episodes so I submit to you
the jury when it comes to the identity
of moroque this additional voices credit
is evidence of nothing just think of
Star Wars with Sam whitworth's voice
always floating around in the background
because Maul is with us always like
saying what we're did an uncredited
voice Cameo as a short trooper and Andor
season 1 episode 7 on the planet niamos
what do you think you're doing you look
like you're sweating if you're not
you heard me tourists don't run you need
to calm down sir Droid assistance please
hang on to this one for me so we can
compare that voice to what we hear from
Baroque in Ahsoka episode three
yeah it kind of sounds like Whitmore has
a higher pitched baritone to his voice
clearly Morocco's voice has been pitched
down and I guess he could say it kind of
sounds like wit word but you know what
Whit were so talented and so versatile
that every male voice through a mask is
gonna sound like him especially if you
go into this expecting that to be
whitworth's voice it's called
confirmation bias folks now the best way
to get into the Star Wars spirit for
Ahsoka is to pick up a tea from our new
World Series line we have imagined a
softball league from a galaxy far far
away with teams like kashyyk Kessel and
Beyond the designs come in three-quarter
baseball shirts the wide striped Sleeve
football tees and in just regular tees
embrace the light and the dark side of
the nerd jock Spectrum at the same time
and if you're looking to soak up Ahsoka
you can grab the fulcrum balance or
Galactic graffiti tees for your next
watch party and if you think nerd Riot
isn't working on a really cool line of
designs for Loki season 2 you've
probably been eating too much of that
toxic green pie from the TVA break room
join the riot over at nerd riot.shop
really I think the biggest evidence
against morocc being Starkiller is
moroak's power set Starkiller is a beast
he goes toe-to-toe with Vader he holds
his own against the emperor Ahsoka has
defeated inquisitors before but against
Vader she would have lost had Ezra not
pulled her through the portal into the
world Between Worlds now moroque in
episode 2 put up a strong fight Paul
Darnell stuntwork incredible but these
were not Starkiller moves so as with
Ezra if marook were revealed to be
Starkiller I think there'd be some
temporary excitement it's seeing Sam
whitworth's face but I just think it
would ultimately be a version of
Starkiller that fans don't really
recognize it would kind of just be Galen
Merrick and Sam whitworth's face in
voice only so let's look back at the
evidence that matters moroque was an
Inquisitor all the inquisitors we know
of were Jedi during the time of The
Purge and they were captured by the
Empire and turned into Jedi hunters and
Vader despised them he killed several of
them and by the time of the battle of
Gavin and a new hope that zero BBY Vader
was believed to be the only practitioner
alive of what was called the ancient
religion by Imperial leadership in a new
hope so the fact that Morocco survived
is very unusual he would have had to
have gone unseen by Vader good luck with
that or protected by the emperor so I
think the real truth about maroque lies
in his name and his helmet it's not that
moroque sounds like Merrick the name and
this spelling actually comes from
Arthurian Legend sir morocc was The
Bodyguard of King Arthur morocc's wife
working for the witch Morgan lafaye
turns him into a wolf or a werewolf and
binds that spell to a Talisman and yes
we should acknowledge it's another
instance of wolf imagery on the series
as Dave filoni is obsessed with wolves
and loath wolves skull and hot T being
references to the Norse mythology wolves
who chase the Sun and the Moon and Dave
filoni's X-Wing pilot is named Trapper
wolf really I think marook's helmet
isn't a nod to the eighth Brother The
Inquisitor who died but rather a
medieval style helmet like an Arthurian
Knight and you may have noticed the red
lights on the side of its helmet and the
angled bulge in the back whenever he
turns his head the light would line up
with the red light on the temples of the
aj-6 cyborg construct like the one worn
by lobot in The Empire Strikes Back so I
just wondered Baroque might have been an
Inquisitor controlled with a cyborg
attachment or perhaps if we're sticking
with the wolf theme Here a shitstavanian
the wolf-like species that was
originally in the Cantina Bar in A New
Hope a morocc could be a former Jedi a
schistobanian who survived Order 66 turn
Inquisitor assigned a bodyguard
Palpatine or one of Palpatine's clone
strand casts one of whom became Rey's
father remember that and that maroque in
the aftermath of Palpatine's death was
lost and looking for a new Mission and
here he is now I'll admit it's not as
sexy of a theory as Ezra or Galen
Merrick Sam Whitworth but I think it's
more satisfying to just let moroque have
a new backstory than to potentially ruin
another character by putting them under
the mask so who is maroque I think he's
just Baroque people and I know the
fandom wants a Mephisto for this series
but wow Mephisto made one of his more
fun for some of us morocc is more like
the aerospace engineer Madness where we
were definitely barking up trees for no
reason because I think people saw what
new rockstars was doing Mephisto and
learned all the wrong lessons for that
experience so stop asking who morocc is
instead just ask who built the star map
because I think that answer is going to
be far more interesting and to that end
please watch our video translating all
the runes in the star map in the
episode's closing credits because it's
just gonna be extremely valuable for all
of us and please support us with an
Ahsoka inspired fulcrum shirt at nerd
riot.shop subscribe to the break room
for our Wikileaks after shows and to the
Deep dive you can follow me at EA boss
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time bye
[Music]